Alhamdulillah.
He was
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala speak out
the the ancient house of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
The Kaa
was built definitely by Ibraimisam.
However, the question that the scholars
differ on is whether or not it was built
originally by Ibraim
or whether it was rebuilt by Ibraim.
We know that the first house of Allah on
the earth
is the capital
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala refers to
it as the ancient house of Allah
and there were many prophets and
messengers on the earth before
Ibraimisam.
For this reason, the correct opinion
amongst the Muslim scholars, the
scholarship of Islam is that the Ka was
built by Adam.
And of course, over time it, you know,
flooding and and and wind and natural
disasters and time and so forth, it had
to be re rebuilt a number of times,
most notably by Ibraim.
And then following that most notably by
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam and
his people before he was made into a
prophet or before he was appointed as a
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam. The
point here is that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala speaks about the ka speaks about
the house of Allah
and he says subhanahua in the next verse
in
that is that whoever exalts
exalts
the sacred sacred places of Allah
then that is the best for that person
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala part of
our worship of Allah
is that we exalt not only Allah but
anything that is ascribed to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala we exalt the people
of Allah we exalt the prophets and
messengers of Allah we exalt the houses
of Allah
We exalt the people of knowledge, the
people of Allah.
We exalt them. All of this is part of
what? The exaltation of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
And anything that is sacred sacred
whether it be a time that is sacred, a
place that is sacred, an act that is
sacred, right? And that is that we exalt
things in a number of ways, but it's not
most notably our exaltation of the house
of Allah. See, there's there's a balance
that has to be had. The balance there is
we want to be able to accommodate and
bring everyone and allow as much into
the house of Allah and the masid as
possible.
However, the balance is we can never
allow anything that we bring into the
masid to impede the purpose of the
masid.
What is the purpose of the masid? The
prophet sallall.aii wasallam says
he says
He said the masid there was a man a
bedin man that came into the masid. Many
of us have heard the narration
and you know he's a bedin which is kind
of if you imagine with me
somebody that is very uncultured
somebody that lives a life that is very
kind of primitive if you can imagine the
most hillbilly of hillbillies in America
right someone that is just they have
their own kind of way of living very
different. They're very uncultured. They
don't have you know much class. They
don't have He came into the masid. He
was a believer. He believed in the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. But he was
not someone that came to the masid
often. And so he went to a corner in the
masid and he started to urinate in the
masid. Now of course there wasn't carpet
in the masid. It wasn't you know it
was just dirt. It was a dirt floor
and where he comes from how things are.
He thought that that was appropriate.
And so the companions
saw this and they got extremely angry
and they were very close to beating this
man and forcefully removing him. The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said
don't stop him let him finish now cuz we
have two options here. Either he
finishes it all in one place or he
finishes it in many places. Let him
finish. And so when he finished, he told
them to bring a bucket of water and to
pour it on the urine. And he said to the
man, "Come here." And he said, "These
mass
these kinds of things are not
appropriate in the masid. These massagid
what they are built for is the
remembrance of Allah and a salah and the
recitation of Quran. What we understand
from this narration
is not that these are the only things
which are permissible in the masid and
anything outside of these is haram.
The scholars did not understand that
from this narration.
Rather what is in understood from this
narration is that this is the purpose of
this building. This is a building but we
use it as a conduit between us and Allah
in order to become closer to Allah. It's
a place that its environment
is geared towards
cultivating a relationship between
the servant and Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. That's the purpose of it.
Anything that is permissible
may be permissible in the masid as long
as it does not impede this
which is the worship of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala what the masid was built for.
And you know often times when we speak
about that balance, the balance of I
want to bring my children, I want to
bring everybody into the masid, but as
well I want to maintain the exaltation
of the masid.
We all have to share this space, right?
And so we have to give and take with
each other. We would never imagine
that we say to everybody, bring all your
family and your kids out and then we
expect them to be absolutely silent.
That is impossible for a child to do. As
a matter of fact, if a child is doing
that, probably something is wrong.
That's not a good sign. Children
naturally are curious and they play and
so forth.
However,
the
culture that has started to creep
into our mass which is you know the
masjid is it's a hangout it's
you know the main purpose of it is to
link up with my buddies and you know the
doors are closed so I know the kid is in
the masid they can't get outside
therefore we just let them run free and
scream and yell and so forth There has
to be a medium had right. There has to
be a level of harmony had to where
anyone can walk into the masjid and not
be deterred
by anyone else in their worship of
Allah. In Sah Bkari the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam once came
out of his home into the masjid and he
found the companions were praying right
each of them was praying and they were
reciting in in their respective prayers
loudly
so if you could imagine 10 of us 20 of
us in here each one is in a in his own
prayer but as they're reciting they're
reciting aloud so everyone can hear
everyone. And now the volume is very
high because each is trying to hear
himself.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said
Quran do not
recite the Quran at one another.
And he made it impermissible for a
person to raise his voice in the masid
in reciting the Quran
if it will disturb another person in the
masid. So it's not permissible for a
person to raise his voice while reciting
the Quran in the masid if that
recitation
will disturb someone else in the masid.
This is the Quran.
And so, as we've mentioned many times
before, you know, habits are hard to
change. And we're all understanding. I
have kids. , you know, I I love to see
my kids in the masid, but from a very
very young age as as as
they became of age to where they could
understand what I was saying to them and
they could understand the difference
between a library and a masid and a
playground.
I
tried to teach them, do not ever raise
your voice in the masid. This is not a
place that is any other building.
This is a very holy place. And how do we
treat a holy place?
We we keep it clean. This is exalting
the messenger. We keep it clean. We keep
it quiet. The prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam said
beware of the rumblings and the sound of
the marketplace in the masid. And so you
know sometimes when if I when I say this
a person might feel personally offended
or attacked and you know oh she ali
is you know extreme or he doesn't like
my kids or he doesn't kids. No I
love kids. Anybody who knows me knows
that she Ali loves kids especially now
cuz my kids are far away. They're in
another country. I'm substituting my
children with your children, right? I
to be around children as much as
possible, but what is the point of
bringing our children to the masid if
they don't know that it is a masid?
What's the point of that?
And if we were all right now as a masid,
if we received an invitation to the Oval
Office
from the president's desk,
it doesn't matter who the president is,
let it be the president that you admire
the most. Who is it? JFK, , Lincoln,
whoever it is, imagine this that you
rece MCCT
received an invitation to the Oval
Office of the President of the United
States of America and bring your
children. Would we bring our children
dressed in pajamas? Would we bring our
kids and when we get in the Oval Office
say, "Hey, go nuts, guys. Just run
around, right? grab stuff off the
shelves, knock things over, play with
the microphones, grab the pens off his
Would we allow that to happen? When we
go to the library, do we allow that to
happen? No, we don't. But the idea is,
well, you know, that kids and you don't
want to make him feel bad cuz if you
make your kid feel bad, he's going to
grow up, you know, , with trauma. like
kids are some delicate little tiny
flower that if you just say the wrong
thing one time, they'll be messed up for
life. This is not how kids are and this
is not the real world. Right? Children
will never grow up and say, "I wish my
dad let me play more." But they will
grow up and say, "I wish my dad taught
me more. I wish my mom taught me more. I
wish that they taught me a culture of
exaltation of the masid. Right? When we
say we want the kids to be in the masid,
it's not just come and fill the building
up. We want them to come and learn. This
is a sacred place. Don't raise your
voice in the masid. Say bismillah, enter
with your right foot. Make sure that
you're clean. Don't touch anything,
right? That is that is not yours, etc.
the things that we teach our children
when we live in civilized society. Even
when we go to the grocery store, we have
rules and the kids know it and they
adhere to those rules. And so this is
something that takes time. We have to be
patient with each other and so forth.
But don't think bad of me when I correct
something or when I mention it to you.
There's nothing at all personal here.
There's nothing at all that says
children are not allowed in the masid or
they shouldn't play in the masid. No.
But within reason,
within reason, right? Because this is a
shared space and because it is the house
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala because it
is a place we have to teach and instruct
our children. I'll leave you with this
one final narration.
Malik
narrated
that the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said
[Silence]
The prophet sallallah.aihi wasallam, our
prophet, he said at the end of time
there will be Muslims that will sit in
groups in their masid. The only thing
that they are discussing
each time and every time is the affairs
of the dunya. They do not remember Allah
in their gatherings. The prophet
sallall.aii wasallam said Allah has no
use for them. So do not sit in their
company. Doesn't mean that saying
something of the dunya is haram in the
masid. But when the masid turns into a
rotary club, how can we then turn it
back? And if a person wishes to escape
the dunya to get closer to Allah,
where's he going to go? I mean, look,
even now the Cabba has turned.
People are there it's a tourist
attraction. They've got their phones out
and everybody's taking pictures and
videos and selfie sticks and it it's
become so difficult to find a place to
worship Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. So we
have to always remind ourselves and
instruct our children and make sure that
we maintain civility especially in the
house of Allahham.
Alhamdulillah.
I think this is